donc sophia aram sur france inter a
égratigné isabelle morini-bosc talus
coupole extrait on voit l'expert un brin
regarde aujourd'hui en 2018 en france
peu importe que men elle présente ses
excuses
ou pas parce que l'occasion est trop
belle pour libérer la boîte à cons de
toutes les médiocrates faisandé du paf
ergotant sur l'opportunité de chanter en
arabe à la télévision par les temps qui
courent comme le susurre discrètement
l'empa fait médiatique isabelle morini
bosc
quand d'autres pointent la provocation
qui consiste je cite à porter un voile
en public comme le vomi le croiser
décati ivan rioufol
autant de propos abjects tenus par des
adultes maîtrisant parfaitement l'outil
médiatique et leurs responsabilités en
matière de vivre ensemble voilà donc
sophia aram qui s'en prend à vous alors
sociale
elle accepte les excuses de mme enel
mais elle n'a pas accepté vos excuses en
fait puisque vous êtes excusé le
lendemain
isabelle donc dans cette émission est
donc sophia aram
elle vous en veux toujours nous les
excuses de tout le monde comme on a dit
qu'on a tous le droit à une deuxième
chance
on l'a toujours dit ici dans cette
émission là encore dit tout à l'heure
sur un autre sujet isabelle est ce que
vous avez quelque chose à lui répondre
comment est la parole est totalement
libre le choix de sophie c'est de parler
comme ça c'est pour faire ça donc j'ai
sofia j'ai été j'étais juste on
s'habille ça je voudrais surtout pas que
puis je pense que je suis ce qu'elle dit
que je suis c'est sympa voilà elle elle
ne représente qu elle donc la parole est
libre
je ne voudrais pas que les gens pensent
que je suis ça ce qui est totalement
faux en revanche manifestement n'a pas
vu l'émission
non mais je pense à elle a retenu deux
mots c'est son choix mais en revanche on
l'avait dit nous sommes ici vous avez eu
des mots malheureux
voilà qu'on tout à fait j'avais dit que
aussi que j'étais sans voile ne me
gênait pas et que j'étais contre son
éviction
mais si vous ne cessez de plus en plus
on voit vous gênez seriez pas de cette
émission puisque tous les soirs en riz
et à maguelone personne voilée dont
public et sont les bienvenus et vraiment
et un jour je me demande moi si on va
pas mettre une personne voilée aux
chroniqueurs une personne avec une kippa
j'ai voulu faire je vous dis la vérité
vendredi dernier je voulais mettre une
personne voilée une personne avec une
kippa
mais malheureusement le vendredi soir
j'ai trouvé personne avec une kippa
s'échappe
c'est pas une balle ok voilà mais je le
fais le soleil se couchera plus tard
mais voilà donc j'attends voilà
j'attends que ça maintenant